welcome to this video panopticon
panopticon government what is he going
to do limbs or Indian maybe at least I
save a couple of seconds because i have
no flag to guess okay what line is he
aiming for what looks like maybe once to
go for the huebner line with 96 and
bishops III maybe okay not just the main
line of the ruined stone now 96 is
possible that captures yep taking and
Bishop takes b6 is the so-called cup of
line yep one of the main lines of the
news on nowadays or not only nowadays
for the last number of years I really
don't know that too well hmm maybe we
need to look do you one I don't know
this also queen bee three maybe but the
pan it always irritates me if there is a
possible capture on c3 but maybe I can
still start with this takes I can also
take with the rook okay
yeah but if he takes with the bishop is
really weakens the light squares quite
substantially i dunno if it is really a
good idea maybe just centralized he is
taking it okay he has got a very
concrete idea understandably okay so I
cannot exchange that this would kill the
dark squares really maybe go here as
usual plate instantly maybe it is good i
don't say it isn't but there were also
bishop d6 and other moves that were very
much worthy of consideration ok yeah
probably he will hit a will take end ok
i go here to correct some what my pawn
structure and i have the FD five yeah
okay come on he is just playing
instantly for no reason d5 as possible
and i can also consider to take only 60
m 1-93 ads also also good maybe go here
is the simplest way to play now my pawn
structure is a problem but his
development also is let's see Bishop e6
he's got drunk f7 to defend this and
there's also d5 but d5 maybe 95 possible
if i take h5 but i can also do that
actually it's not not bad I take age
five come on let's let's do that check
ok I can take with the Queen and then d5
taking what the point is probably not
really great
yep activate activate milks
okay just de 6m probably go for the deep
on yeah I will pour down or this is Ted
strange but it is still not at all clear
to me because well i lost the h porn but
i have this deep on and it's not easily
blockaded the night is not a very
reliable blockade ahem because i have a
light squared Bishop and my pieces are
all all in play maybe you can try nights
e5 e6 f4 or something like that it's
possible but ok I'll go diesel Janet
okay he just a for a moment now okay I
don't have time for a moment i can take
d7 now take five but he has rookie aid
okay rook c7 probably not
I can take and play Queen d3 simply then
rooks is seven not sure if it is the
best but it's it's playable it's a
playable continuation it also has the
week back rank so something that group
the ADA I can just play Roxy seven
yeah very very tough position okay time
warning yeah let's just take this for
the moment check em check this is just
an excellent and game I have the tube to
pass us on the queenside he's got the
edge porn but my king is near that
now they're not very mobile though my
pawns I need I need to waste some time
to get them going it's not that clear
when I rupee 5a 5b for this kind of
mechanism but not sure if it it should
win now I need to I need to account the
h-bond snow okay now I just let them
roll
yes hoping for counter play with a faux
end and stuff check but this is really
quick rook b6 now a threat with Luke a 6
that's easiest chatters promote this
black resigns yeah i know i'm always
sort of criticizing the quick play but
this was really an interesting position
and irie don't understand why you need
to play it in or instantly as it was so
obvious Bishop d6 for example is is an
interesting move but ok didn't do it
yeah and here interesting there are many
possibilities but ultimately I need to
claim I went I went for this to cover
computer points out queen bee hive which
gives what a substantial advantage they
are not surprised I'm simply how better
developed so it's not clear that this is
weakening of the pawn structure meaning
much I'm just attacking the knight iam
it's a very good to rename this I can
just take here take here there is no
checkmate queen a tree Bishop f1 yeah he
black is ok chat corny to the to the
computer yeah it really does not believe
in my position I wasn't I wasn't so sure
in fact he can take him ok and play this
ah this is I've totally over I don't
really threaten the night because of
Queen Airy check yeah this changes the
position dramatically I was always
thinking he cannot take it because of
because of rock d5 and I'm attack
here I'm attacking the night but he has
this defense iam yeah this changes the
position as mentioned dramatically I
thought he has no move here really and I
wouldn't the piece okay yeah this means
my whole play is bogus beforehand
probably ma'am I need to do that here
but it's really not good I can do this
maybe this is then what I should do
being a pawn down like like this yeah
that's not convincing I thought I can do
the central break through my real miss
however was the screen b5 move yeah very
complicated situation him okay so he
played this and no d6 yeah and here I'm
not really sure yeah computer prefers
black quite clearly but with what rook
adah I thought it wasn't so clear any
maybe maybe a while the computer is
merciless of course night f6 Andrew
create two seconds it's maybe better
than this I don't know here here it's
unequal which I find quite maybe if this
is quite quite right and here now I just
played this known to KU check
yak 27 in two seconds I find remarkable
but I don't know I've given up to
understand why some moves are played
instantly sorry and Chang it's really a
big decision to allow the end game check
with white having two passes the
computer gives black it clear to decide
this is this is I cannot believe at all
I'm really sorry how should black have a
clear cheer maybe I don't get get the
pawns going possible it's possible okay
this this was played and then I get a
foreign the computer wants to play this
and you have this this is something I
understand I understand I must play
three otherwise I'll lose stuff and now
it's really quite it it takes quite a
while until this point we roll yeah yeah
yeah I don't really think I'm in
substantial trouble but I understand why
blood like me maybe could be better ok I
can I can go here and fight against the
h-bond there's only this porn at the
moment I cannot get my pawns going
quickly so it's possible yeah that's
really possible that this is okay for
black or even not okay i mean probably
maybe an edge but really i look before a
fall does this takes time but i don't
really see what being worse IAM cannot
believe it really how is he going to get
his sponsor promoted in some way with
mocking albanian defense the double porn
is not shot such a big problem yeah hard
to tell when in the game to just wrap it
up quickly around here i start to have a
serious advantage that
that's pretty clear here the computers
on plus two already probably need some
time to get higher now an plus 3 here
yeah white will promote him this is what
I had envisioned when I exchange screens
but I didn't really spot that the check
chatham he should play croquet 7
immediately this is a big difference
really slowing me down considerably ok
thanks for watching